Aloha I'm Jason Momoa and I'm going to
do interviews with BuzzFeed and puppies
I'm very excited bring me my puppies
oh my goodness
hi
did you already go poop
I didn't they kind of found me I was 19
and I ended up being in the right place
and I got onto the show because of my
family who are watermen I just fell in
love with acting after that
I really had to find my inner child you
know it helped because my son is the
same age as I was playing he's 12 years
old Marla was exceptional she was
amazing so I think she really saved the
day and it was just uh it's all her
movie and I was happy to be a part of it
gosh we had so much fun me and my my
daughter made up this dance to do a Lipa
we do it in the and do it in the movie
and so my kids are teaching me and Marla
learned it and so we're learning it so
maybe I'll post that today that was a
good behind the scenes
I'm doing it right now in Chief of War
so I'm playing this character called
cutiana
and he travels from Hawaii and travels
to China and Alaska and comes back and
he's a part of the unification of the
Hawaiian Islands with Kamehameha yeah
that's like a dream come true it's been
15 years in the making to do that get
over here mister
I think it was Dune going to Jordan was
pretty amazing I'm a rock climber so
then we even went there back for we went
to uh wadiram again for my show uh The
Climb which we're doing comes out soon I
was so stoked when I saw the Rocks there
then we went out there and went climbing
to
I have something on right now probably
yeah I'm a natural born Thief so I kind
of take everything from set everything I
touch and wear I take
be with my babies ride motorcycles rock
climb I love rock climbing so I'm being
outdoors if there's something that I can
do to help with the environment or bring
awareness things like that
oh yeah and none of your goddamn
business wear
[Music]
foreign things you can do in your home
and in your community shopping locally
supporting locally things with Lighting
in your house your car riding to work I
mean there's all types of things that
you can do for your own health and for
the planet so and then definitely stop
seeing all these plastic because it just
it goes right into our environment
uh the one on my chest of my children's
um just signature they wrote for the
first time to blow the wolf
foreign
this is weird but friends because my
daughter's obsessed with friends
hopefully being the Eco Warrior saving
the planet bringing awareness working
with Scientists just trying to make the
world a better place
big dogs
my mom's gonna love this oh you're very
nice what's your name look come here is
that a great
thing yep hi
[Music]
thanks ma all right Mom I gotta do this
interview love it okay bye oh oh what's
this concluded
which I wish there's more um
oh yes I mean I mean our whole history
understanding what's happened to Hawaii
that we're actually occupied that it's
not an actual State as many things
oh I would love to work as Amelia I mean
I love to work with kit too Amelia do a
romantic comedy because I'm tired of
getting beat up do you do pause
can you pause
okay what else
pretty much everyone I call answers
right away bro want to dance for my
FaceTime right now chalamet wouldn't
pick up Rolling Wood but they just both
they both reached out yes because
they're doing June two do you like did
you like doing
not very good so I'm Jason Momoa and
this is snuffalump I guess and we are
gonna watch Slumberland on Netflix
November 18th please watch I play flip
and who do you put
you play Pig you all love it all these
beautiful pets are available online
they're up for adoption at
wagmorepets.org yay we did it it's
really hard to do interview with puppies